the title of this is wasm components the
interchangeable parts of software so
brief introduction to myself I like to
give this this is the thing of like why
you should listen to me
um first off I'm a director of customer
engineering at cosmonic you've seen a
lot of us today I am a restation by way
of go being a gopher beforehand I did a
lot of go and then a lot of rest
um
I'm a I'm one of the co-creators of
creslet and bindle so if you're here in
this room you've probably at least heard
of creslet it was the first attempt to
really try to do something with
webassembly and unknown technology and
then bindle's a thing that we can talk
more about on the side I am an open
source maintainer I used to be a core
maintainer of Helm I actually wrote a
large chunk of Helm 3 along with some of
the people here who are now at fermion
and then a couple others who I worked
with like some of the folks from VMware
who used to be at binomi so
um and done a lot of that I've done
kubernetes thing since kubernetes 1.2
lots of stuff with Docker for a very
long time so I built kubernetes
platforms at various companies and now
I'm doing a lot of things with love
assembly so that's a little bit about me
that's the background that kind of uh
goes into the Talk itself so here's what
we're gonna do we're going to go through
a brief history lesson first and after
we talk about a brief history lesson
we're going to talk a little bit about
was in cloud and components some of this
you heard from Brooks today this is also
a bit of a follow-on to what Luke talked
about this morning
I'm going to talk about the status quo
where we're at with wasm cloud and then
what we're doing right now and why it
actually matters for this whole
components thing and then we'll talk
about the challenges we faced and the
future of components inside of
webassembly
so let's start off with a brief history
of the 20th century I tried to make that
as a college class sounding as possible
just so uh I'm not actually going to
make it boring so at the very beginning
of the 20th century in the United States
there was two important manufacturing
Concepts that merged together and that
was the assembly line hint hint and um
the the idea of interchangeable parts
now this is the definition of
interchangeable parts directly from
Wikipedia I did not doctor this to
include these words like components and
assembly I promise I pulled it straight
from from uh Wikipedia and put it on
here and there's just a couple important
things here they are parts or components
that are that are identical for
practical purposes
um so there may be the very specific
specifications and it allows easy
assembly of the new devices and easier
repair of the devices that do exist and
that minimizes both the time and skill
required of the person doing said
repairing or assembling
that sounds a lot like what we want web
assembly components to do if you're
listening to Luke's talk this morning
and so what this looks like in practice
with with compo like when these were
created is you had these part diet part
diagrams that were spread out and they
were created to be something that was
basically like a
um you could take any one of these parts
and reassemble them and in the picture
on the right you see an old like
assembly line from the early 1900s in
the United States and
there were buckets of screws and bolts
and things that were all the exact same
size and you could just go down grab it
and put it in
and so because each part is produced to
those exact specifications this is what
this whole like these two things
combining is what kicked off what people
called the Industrial Revolution
now this whole lesson of what happened
actually has surprising applications to
software development as well and so
we're going to continue with just a
little bit of History lesson with about
like where guazam is wasm cloud and the
different components that came through
so if you think about it at this point
enough software is created probably on a
daily basis that it is essentially like
an assembly line all of this code reuses
various pieces of someone else's code
and honestly the best we've been able to
do are apis and apis are nowhere near
interchangeable parts
components have a little bit different
work but when I say apis I mean
everything graphql rest soap
grpc doesn't matter that's that's the
way we've that's a communication
protocol that's not an actual
interchangeable part
and so where we've at this is a history
of the modern Computing environment you
saw this slide earlier with what Brook
said but I want to expand just a little
bit more on it
um we started right from like the old
like blades in a data center I mean
there's some of us I have done this too
where you know like if you haven't if
you haven't pulled a spinning disc out
of a running server and had it wrench
the arm out of your like your arm out of
its socket I don't know if you've lived
life as a programmer but um anyway so
these are these are the kinds of things
that like we started with and we've gone
through this idea of a VM which
abstracted a little further in a
container which built on top of that and
then webassembly itself
and so along this path we've gone really
far along the path through usability but
we haven't gotten all the way there
and as Brooks had mentioned earlier wasm
cloud is
the is a system that allows us to
abstract a little bit further and
Abstract out these non-functional
requirements so I'm going to talk a
little bit about that once again you'll
see these slides are similar because
Brooks and I wrote them together that's
why he had these same ones but I'm going
to go into different details we've all
talked about webassembly to death we're
all here because we know about it we
know what it does these are the main
things that we want to do with it
portable secure small fast language
agnostic all those different things
now the thing is this wasm is almost
nothing without an application runtime
on top of it because at its very base
level I'm talking the base level I'm not
talking about all this other cool stuff
that's going on it's numbers in numbers
out there's not there's not a lot more
than that you you're you're that's how
you're restricted to use a webassembly
module and in our in our case what
wasn't cloud is an application runtime
we've created it's a cncf project so
this is entirely open source and I'm
focusing purely on the open source here
not cosmonic cosmotic is powered by
Watson Cloud but this is all the wasm
cloud side of things
and it's it's focused on removing that
boilerplate code that boilerplate code
that I talked about that and the
non-functional requirements we don't
care about
and all this comes with this idea of
horizontally and vertically scalable
however we do it but the big thing here
are these capabilities
now capabilities you'll kind of notice
that this whole idea that we've talked
about before the idea of capabilities is
very similar to what Luke was explaining
the component model this is a common
problem in our industry the thing is is
the component model is all about the
bits of pieces that get compiled to run
on your machine
what we call capabilities is the
distributed form of that I want to have
something that satisfies my the need for
my my software and I want to plug it in
and I want to do that in some way that
is distributed
and on top of that we write our actual
webassembly actors the things that that
consume these data sources these
capabilities
and these all run on top of our lattice
they're the completely flat topology
distributed Network that that is
connecting every single wasm Cloud host
application runtime this is the part
that actually makes it distributed when
you combine all this together you get
the distributed capabilities on top
now I'm going to talk about the
differences between those in just a
second but first I want to review what
are components
um like like I said Luke already talked
about this in depth but for our
discussion here these are just a few
points to keep in mind first off
components are these interchangeable
parts I've been referring to they allow
us to glue different things together in
the way we want them to
um wasn't cloud has capabilities which
are these distributed components
um but we'll still see that there's
underlying dependencies that can get
compiled in
so with that let's talk about the status
quo where do things stand with wasm
Cloud right now from this part of the
talk line I'm going into deep technical
detail but you don't have to understand
a lot about webassembly to to understand
the concepts I'm going to talk about but
this is going to be very practical about
what we're doing so first off just the
super high level of how this works this
is the current diagram of how things
work inside of wasm cloud
um anything that's in blue is user
managed code so it's code that the user
is compiling or doing something with I
mentioned we have this lattice the
lattice is what delivers messages to and
takes messages that are going out from
an actor and sends them back out to
whatever else it needs to be sent to and
all that runs inside of a wasm cloud
host but you'll notice that there is
this wasn't bus RPC Library that's in
there this this library is a custom
Library we have to have that allows us
to transmit this data properly it has
all the encoding and a bunch of other
things that are in that are necessary
for it to run whenever you write an
actor for Watson Cloud you have to pull
in this Watson bus RPC dependency
and now it's only a few dependencies but
it's still not ideal because you're
pulling in code that then if we have to
update you have to update
and that's the problem that got us here
in the first place if you think the
basic example I used to explain this to
anyone who asks is think about the log
4J thing that happened okay because
first off it's not about the bug we've
all written stupid bugs I mean
let's be honest with ourselves we've
taken down production once or twice or
10 times and so the the whole idea
behind that was now oh we had containers
we're all secure well okay now we have
this core dependency that a bajillion
things use and now we have to go update
and recompile all the code and then
recompile all the containers and then
redeploy all the containers
that is not what we want to do and we've
managed to abstract out a lot of that
with these capabilities we've talked
about the ability to say oh I want a key
value store so let me let me just code
against a key Value Store contract and
then I'll choose how I connect it later
but they're still underlying code that
gets coupled in and that's something we
don't really like to have
and so what this ends up being this
right here do not worry about the whole
everything that's in this code block you
don't have to do it everything here is
going to be rust today you don't have to
understand a lot about rust to
understand what's going on here but
you'll note at the very top these
dependencies okay there's a couple of
them we have this was and bus RPC and
then we have the two different
interfaces we have the interface HTTP
server that's in there and we have the
interface key value and so it's still
really simple this is a simple actor
that does it receives an HTTP request it
takes that path and uses it as a key and
then increments how many times that path
has been hit just a very simple example
that takes an HTTP server and then
stores it stores a bit of data into
place and we have gotten it down like
this is still really small this is maybe
42 I think there's 42 lines of code I
don't have the line numbers on there but
these are these are 42 lines of code so
we got it small but we have all these
things up top that are importing in
things that you don't manage
and so what this also means for us is
that if we want to do this for any
language for every single language we
need to support we have to generate
interface type interfaces for them
release them and then also have a
wasenbus RPC for every single language
now yes we have some underlying API
encodic stuff that you could use but
that's not the ideal way for people to
consume this so you can start to see
this becomes very hard to scale out and
it's a custom piece of code that we
don't want to always handle
so let's go into what we're actually
doing and why it matters and now we're
going to really get really get technical
but once again always start back up at
this high level keep this diagram in
mind as we jump into it because we're
going to go into every like little
detail on this thing about what's going
on
now on the left is what I showed you
before that's where we're currently at
and what we are currently working on as
in like right now is what's on the right
um with webassembly modules we can start
splitting everything up so only the user
managed code the actual business logic
is all they have to write there's no
other external dependencies they have to
pull in
um this is everything like all to be
clear too to show kind of the benefit of
what wasn't Cloud does for you all of
this other code around it all the other
things that are not blue are things that
wasn't Cloud does for you you this is
code you do not have to write as a user
we're just showing you everything in
here so you know what we're doing so I'm
going to jump into some very specific
examples starting at the top of this
HTTP server and once again this is going
to be a practical example of how we're
implementing components you've probably
heard a lot of stuff about components
being like Oh well components are only
theoretical don't you no they're new
they're not theoretical and so I'm
trying to show you here how we're doing
it
and let's go into it so first off to wit
I've been waiting all day to use that
stupid pun
um so let's talk about let's talk about
wit files
so with files I don't even know if they
technically stand for anything anymore
historically it comes from the wasm
interface types proposal and so that's
where wit comes from but these whip
files are how you define what you want
your thing your contract your interface
to look like and these are API
definition they look like API
definitions but they are not API
definitions they're a bit different in
practice when you actually use them
so this right here for wasm cloud is a
very specific entry point into any actor
there is a receive method that has to be
called in from an inbound message from
that lattice that I've talked about and
we've alighted some things like there's
some common types we're importing and
then we just have the single receive
that is a message that gets passed in
and returns back out a raw payload that
can then be parsed by the underlying
system
so this wit file right here is our HTTP
server one now a lot of these this is
how we Define it for now and as we
continue as we all continue to use
components this is where we start to
standardize on similar interfaces that
become shared across everybody and I'll
get to uh to a little bit more about
that later right now this is what our
HTTP server looks like and
and you'll see we have the request the
response and then some other little
types that help things out
um and then at the very bottom you'll
see the only method that we have for
this contract is handle request it has
to be something that receives an HTTP
request and returns a response
so this slide this is what it's all
looking like in code at the very top
this is the line from that original
piece of code I sent you so all of this
that I'm showing underneath replaces
this whole dependency all of its sub
dependencies everything else underneath
it it replaces that line of code inside
the original block
now on the left once again you do not
have to understand all the code here I
left enough for context for those who
really want to dig into this later but
what it what you can see happening is
we're just we're receiving this message
we're matching to make sure it's a
proper type so this is wasn't Cloud
specific codec matching and comes in and
says okay I'm going to pass this off to
a handle request HTTP server handle
request so this magic HTTP server and
the Implement wasn't bus receiver at the
top is coming from something called
cargo component that I'll mention and
this is just inside of our cargo.com
only reason I put this is in this new
world you're going to have to have
something that tells you where your
interface is at and in this case we're
saying we are importing an interface
called HTTP server that we're going to
call and we're exporting something
called wasimbus receiver and so that's
why this implements the function that we
expected right this receive function
receives a message and it is calling
something in Imports which is the HTTP
server so this code will receive the
message turn it into something the HTTP
server knows and then call an HTTP
server it doesn't know which HTTP server
it's calling right now it just knows
that something on the other end is going
to implement that contract
so we've talked about this high level
HTTP server one now I'm going to turn
this like into a sandwich the user
managed code is in the middle of the
sandwich we're going to go to the other
slice of bread and talk about the key
value in the sender because they're very
they're they're closely related
so first off we have the wit files again
now this is a very dumbed down version
of our key value interface that we're
still iterating on that just has the
increment function in real life this
will probably have the get set delete
types of things you'd expect from a key
value function but for now we just for
for proving this out
we wanted to get it to this increment
function so same thing single increment
function it takes a specific value
returns a specific value back and at the
bottom is a thing that is common to
every single actor that runs in in wasm
Cloud this becomes very important and
I'll cover that in a second but right
here it's this send function I want to
be able to send something out on the
lattice and same thing single function
we Define and then we're able to use
so code for this on the left is the key
value.wasm and beneath it you'll see the
line of code that it entirely replaces
from that first example once again
you're like oh well it's just a line of
code but remember that line of code
includes that package whatever language
we're running it or Imports that package
and all of the dependencies that that
package pulls in so we've now removed
that entirely with this with this method
so you'll see that it implements the key
value thing that we've we defined before
in the went file and it's calling a
wasenbus send so basically this takes
all the the incoming thing and says how
do I turn this into Ascend Ascend method
and I I send it across the wire
now on the right
is the sender code now now for our
example we're just giving it a handle to
standard out in real life this will be
connected to the Watson Cloud host which
will expose a function to it and it can
call that function but right now just
for for Simplicity that's how we've done
it so this goes all the way down it gets
this this raw message it doesn't matter
what the message came from handles the
message by sending it out to the host
and then receives and returns data back
now once again this sender is used
everywhere every single actor that will
ever run on a wasam cloud host will use
this code
but what's cool about components is
let's say we have a bug in this
you don't have to recompile your code
you don't even have to redeploy your
code we just go blink and pop in the new
component and it's ready to go
and as components evolve we'll even be
able to do I'm hoping we'll be able to
do things like hot swapping but even if
we don't this is a really quick we're
just shifting it in and next time you
call the the actual actor it's going to
be using the new patched code and you
did nothing and that's a really really
powerful security feature and just very
user-friendly feature
and again all of these different
components could be written in different
languages we could write this in C we
could write the key value thing in
Python the top thing could be written in
Rust and it doesn't matter all of this
code can then just be smashed together
as a component because it's all compiled
down to webassembly you start to see
some of the all these benefits all come
together that we've been mentioning
about webassembly for such a long time
and so
this replaces a lot of our code as well
so just a benefit for us and it I mean
it depends on the use case but for us
this sender thing replaces a whole bunch
of like data copying and serializations
that we have to do to get things into
the right format whereas in with a
component we're able to just talk
directly to the host we're able to use
typed functions and things that can come
down into a host for us
so this is this is a pretty big deal but
what does this all enable for us so we
started off
um with this idea of the HTTP server we
moved to the key value uh What DOT was
in the Watson bus sender that's a lot of
stuff but what does this actually enable
us to do once again I was giving all
this so you know exactly what we're
doing and why but what does it enable
and why is it so powerful
let's look at the key value counter
this is the new key value counter
that we had that comes out of this
you'll notice that this looks almost
identical to the one you you had before
at the very beginning
but now there is zero wasm Cloud
specific code in here
um
Luke mentioned something called virtual
platform layering it might have just it
might have just kind of over people in
between all the awesome details going on
there
but this is an example of virtual
platform layering if we collaborate on
these common contracts because most key
value things everyone is using the same
set of get set and delete sure there's
some extended things people could do and
people are allowed to do that and wasn't
Cloud you can create your own contracts
and you can create your own providers
and implementations but most people are
going to use that same set of
functionality and if we have those
standard things there's nothing stopping
someone from taking an actor they've
written for wasm cloud and running it in
another system
because it uses those same Imports
and so another thing that's important to
point out here is I'm writing normal
rust code there's no yes there's some
magic happening here there's going to be
like the wit bind gen stuff in Rust is
really good and some other languages
like I even showed it's not as good uh
with the whole wit thing
but it doesn't matter this generation
might will happen and I know people get
a little scared of the code generators
but this isn't like the kubernetes code
generators where you're committing this
code this is something that can be
generated on the Fly compiled in and run
and you're just writing normal code for
your language
and to to beat the dead horse again in
wasm Cloud this is the only code you
have to write
you get all of this distributed goodness
I've been talking about the whole
putting together these different things
across a huge distributed platform just
by writing this code and there's no
mention of anything about scaling
nothing about what you're connecting to
none of those details and you can you
can see in the code it's just really
simple it says hi I'm implementing the
HTTP server contract pretend I'm an HTTP
server give me an HTTP request please
that's that first handle request
function
but then when you go down the line you
see
this thing that says oh key value
increment towards the very bottom of
that
what key value nobody knows nor do they
care and nor do most developer
developers care when they're writing
their code
so we've been able to do this with
components and what this allows us to do
in the future is think about this is
like layering components on top of
components in a sense you have an actor
that is running a stack of four
different wasm components Watson modules
that are glued together turned into a
final compiled like webassembly module
for for sake of discussion here and it
runs on a Watson Cloud host but then
you're able to then compose what it's
connecting to just like you did with
edit runtime to whatever thing you want
to connect it to so we basically have
components that make up an actor and
then multiple actors that can talk to
different providers and compose them the
way that you want them to and scale the
way you want to have them scaled
so just a few things about the
challenges that we faced in the future
we're going for to finish up everything
here
so first off this uh diagram so I threw
this together this was a ragey diagram
and on purpose uh gluing this all
together is a bit difficult now I'm
going to be honest Bailey I'm going to
do a shout out to Bailey Bailey did a
lot of this code too to help out
um here and so she discovered a lot of
these things and boy was it a little bit
messy uh it's a bit difficult so right
now this is requiring three separate
tools the Blue Line you see on here
anything below it is what we do on a
wasm cloud host but on the top we have
to have this thing we have to have cargo
component that uses stuff with the wit
files and then we have to use whip
buying gen and wit component to actually
glue the things together it outputs a
wasm file but that wasm file is still
labeled as Watson 32 unknown unknown
because there's no official Watson 32
component thing yet so it's it's a
component but it doesn't say it is when
you look at anyway it gets a little
complicated there and you think you've
made a mistake but you haven't and then
at runtime we have to pull down all the
web assembly modules and put them
together with wasm tools compose to get
a final thing that's how we do it right
now as in like literally right now what
we're trying to make it do to work
ideally in the future this will continue
to improve for us personally we've
started to abstract this away for for
our users behind washbuild
so this is not there yet but we're going
to be adding that all behind there so as
these standards continue to improve and
be just be better overall and more
solidified we'll start rolling into like
just the full tooling but it's still
hidden behind for for our users behind a
wash build command
and then obviously the stuff underneath
we're hiding just by virtue of being a
host that's running it
so that was the first challenge that I
have listed here the second one is you
have to use a runtime that supports the
component model which is wasn't time and
nothing else so that we all love Watson
time I mean that's not a slight against
was entire science it's so new that only
Watson time supports it so you have to
use was some time if you're going to use
components right now
um things are still on the assembly line
huh sorry bad dad joke but the thing is
is we we're on the bleeding edge here
people so things are going to bleed and
that's part of the issue of doing things
with components right now is it is very
very it's hemorrhaging Edge so just make
sure that if you go down this route you
know that that's what you're going to
get into
um also this talk is one of the few real
world examples out there
um there's been some talks about it
today but like there there isn't a lot
out there there's probably three to four
examples of doing this for Realties not
like oh look at this pretty diagram
which are great this is one of the few
real things that are out there that was
why we wanted to to give this talk it's
because we wanted to show a real example
for people who start following along
with even though it's far far far from
perfect
so those are those are the challenges
just keep that in mind I always like
talking about those first we can talk
about the positives here and where we're
going the first thing is that we're
we're going to be implementing this as
soon as possible for wasm cloud
um like I said we don't want to have to
make people include their own Library
like our own library for them to be able
to write something
we um we we're gonna until this point
until the point that we've actually
fully implemented this will keep our our
custom libraries as easy to use as
possible but this is something that
within the next few months we're really
trying to get some first drafts out with
um like I said this code actually runs
it wasn't worth showing the demo because
all it does is print line some stuff but
we're actually this is a real thing that
exists once we get this stuff out with
wasm Cloud we're going to use that to
give any feedback back into the actual
spec for components and how they how
they work and then we're going to also
contribute to it we want to help push it
across the Finish Line just like
everybody else in here we unlock
components we unlock and solve a lot of
problems for pretty much everybody here
who wants to use webassembly and then
we're going to work on things like
having a wasm cloud world now that isn't
a theme park as much as we'd love to
have that it is the world files that
were being mentioned earlier we want to
be able to like work within the world
file things and contribute to that whole
idea of having requirements and virtual
platform layering that goes along
so here's some references this is the
same QR code that Brooks had earlier so
if you already scanned it don't need to
scan it again at least to our slack we
have some uh what a link to Watson
clouds some more things about what our
capability providers are and what our
interfaces currently look like
um they're all there also just as a
heads up we have if you're interested in
learning how to do this we have a
webassembly crash course on Tuesday that
Bailey's putting on with me and a couple
others from cosmonic and tonight after
the uh basically the happy hour at the
Detroit Marriott
there's details online with that QR code
there's we're getting together with our
friends at fermion to do a meet up and
it's meant to be a place where you can
just try out the things that we're doing
and that fermion's doing and just to
have people who know webassembly all
together in the same room so you can
talk about whatever you're hacking on so
that's all I have and I just want to
leave it open for any other questions
[Applause]